that is an impressive rebound here craig  how would you summarize it um yeah i  think i played quite well in this game  um i managed to outplay uh  um  quite good i think i  after b5 i thought i got this 93 knight  f4 i think i'm just completely better  there  it's just one sided game  you always look so calm so composed  after your games but after that first  one today i i you looked more frustrated  than i've seen you before were you  really mad then  uh yeah i was upset uh  because i had  good preparation till some point but  then i i didn't  i didn't check one more and then i  i quickly got into a west position  um  yeah that's why i think i was quite  upset  good luck and congratulations thanks for  watching back yeah thank you